Imagine that you have the code for
the messenger app.
Where would we look to find a swift
statement that presents the image picker
view on top of the composer view.
We would find such a statement in
the View Controller that's currently
on screen.
The compose message view controller.
The invocation looks like this.
Now let's have a closer look
at these three arguments.
The third one is often set to nil.
It's a closure,
which is a block of code that can be
invoked once the view is presented.
This second argument indicates
how the view appears.
When animated is set to false, the view
flashes onto the screen immediately,
without the upward slide.
For this first argument,
we'll need a reference to the view
controller that's being presented.
Let's figure out how
to get that reference.